I couldn't help notice another irony
this week as FoxNews loved the Hillary
story obviously they were like a dog
with a new chew toy and yet not a word
about the Bill O'Reilly situation that
III let me read to you Bill O'Reilly
words and you tell me if he is not just
a blatant bald ass
liar he said I've reported on the ground
in active war zones from El Salvador to
the Falklands no you haven't
there's no gray area here a war zone is
where the war is going on you're in the
capital of a country as it was at war
but the war was 1,200 miles away to Bill
O'Reilly I saw nuns get shot in the back
of the head no you saw pictures of that
Bill O'Reilly I've seen Irish terrorists
kill and maim their fellow citizens in
Belfast with but no again you saw
pictures of it it's not the same thing
I've seen pictures of the Hindenburg I
don't say I saw the Hindenburg go down I
mean
okay
one last one okay there was a guy who
was a friend of a Russian guy in America
he was a friend of Lee Harvey Oswald so
as you might imagine he's been up some
interest to reporters for all the years
after the Kennedy assassination
maybe that's why in 1977 he killed
himself okay here's bill o'reilly on
that in his book killing kennedy as the
reporter knocked on the door he's
talking about this guy's house he heard
the shotgun blast that marked the
suicide of this Russian assuring that
his relationship with Lee Harvey Oswald
will never be fully understood by the
way that reporters name was Bill
O'Reilly no it plainly wasn't there is a
tape of him on the phone with someone
talking about this which happened in
Florida when Bill O'Reilly was in Dallas
with Bill O'Reilly saying I got to get
on a plane to cover this
these are out-and-out lies now I
understand why Fox News backs him
because they're not really a news
service so they're like
they're like you expect the truth that's
not what we do here but why isn't the
mainstream media going after him with
the same ferocity the supposedly liberal
media as they did to Brian Williams
because it Roger I suspect I suspect
it's because they know what you just
said which is Fox News is in the real
news organization and Bill O'Reilly
isn't a real journalist yeah Bill
O'Reilly being full of about
something is not a news story right it
just isn't
okay but it seems amazing the way this
guy gets away November that Scott sex
scandal he had did the same thing just
intimidated people bullied them I mean
he said about this one too in the New
York Times reporter I'm going after you
with everything you have I have you can
take that as a threat you know what if a
liberal reporter said they were in a war
zone
what would the Fox News crowd be saying
they'd be saying oh this is an insult to
troops who are really in the war zone
this bad American you guys there's a
bigger deal to hear though I think bill
bill and the sense that this is you know
O'Reilly has said everything you just
said is not true he said that he can
back up his stuff and I know you
I've read the stories as well Brian
Williams actually came out and said you
know what I did do this stuff and I'm
apologizing for to NBC News I think had
less that they could deal I mean they
had to either accept that and go with it
box is gonna defend him as long as he's
saying but I did what I said I did and
nobody else is really able to challenge
I'll move on but just till we know there
is no gray area here
he said I was on a doorstep when there's
proof he wasn't he said he saw things
when this proof he wasn't he claims that
evidence doesn't exist so and there's
clearly I mean in any journalist knows
the difference between being in a war
zone and not being in a war zone and
it's in Ohio if you're no war zone you
know it's you know